are you still be Comcast SportsNet
mid-atlantic host Michael still
gainfully employed yeah believe it
believe it or not alright when did you
come up with this well the funny thing
is is that we actually came up with this
kind of on the fly and you know I had a
normal sports cast plan and we do a lot
of fun stuff we do a lot of bits and
commentaries and stuff like that stuff
that we actually thought would would do
better than this would do and so just
about half an hour before the show we'd
already had three or four hours of
Capitol's coverage and I thought you
know what everyone's seen the same
highlights they've seen the same
reaction let's have some fun with it and
sort of project the disappointment that
everyone feels right now so I went out
like I'm gonna pretend I'm drinking on
air I'm just gonna pretend I'm drinking
on air and I'm gonna do it the entire
show and so I went and I found the one
glass that you could see through in the
entire station I filled it up and went
on air and just kind of went with it
and I mean it's done this just how much
it just took off and we kind of live
with it from there what was in the glass
mantle iced tea did anybody try to talk
you out of it no I mean we actually do
stuff not maybe that extreme we do
little things like this all the time so
for us it wasn't that big of a deal we
all thought it was funny we thought oh
yeah this would be great
be hilarious we'll have some fun with it
and that was the end of it for us but of
course on a national scale people aren't
familiar with us so it was like oh my
god what are these guys doing how could
they think of such a thing how did this
guy actually chug bourbon a live TV
unbelievable and we actually just didn't
think it was that big of a deal at the
time the thing I got in trouble most
welcome
men to entrusted me here the thing that
they were really upset about is that I
ruined an $800 microphone because I
spilled my drink on it though the actual
issue oh I thought you were gonna have
some backlash on talking to kids about
their dreams
amazingly everyone's kind of related to
that said yeah that's uh yeah you're
spot-on there did management say
anything are they there they're aware of
this yes yeah
they were uh I didn't really say
anything because there was nothing I
mean I feel bad because there were so
many people that wanted to believe that
I was drinking on air so either way it
was like look you need to play into that
or you can you know lose your job so no
management was they were fine with it
they know sort of my style and I always
try to make sports as fun as it can be
and so it just it really wasn't an issue
the issue really was microphone more
than anything else but no they were
completely supportive and really happy
with it and the Capitals really make you
drink though Michael Oh Dan yes this
team is you know the DC sports in
general we haven't I mean most people
know we haven't won a title I mean I've
been here for 11 years I've never
covered a championship team and one of
the four major sports and the people
that have been here longer than I have
and so I mean I live right in the city I
feel like I'm a part of this city and I
really want our local teams to do well
but the people who've been here longer
than me have experienced a drought even
longer and the Capitals in particular
the one team we thought I this is the
year especially after all these years
where there's disappointment
disappointment and this was the year we
thought now this is this is the year we
actually break through and so for that
actually actually once again end up with
this crushing disappointment I think
that's why people related to it because
if you're a Cavs fan at all or a hockey
fan you've been there it's like you know
what I'm just gonna add some drinks
because this starts all over again if
you were going to apply for another job
would you put what happened with the
drinking on that resume real that's a
great question I mean I would say
probably not because there's just not
the context there in the context of you
know the three people that are familiar
with my career then and I've done this
for 20 years so it's it's one thing in a
host of things I've done but for you
know 99.9% of the people out there
people looking at me for a potential
chopped it would be like oh yeah that's
the drunk guy so yeah I would
probably not put that on a resume and
hope that that sort of just fades into
the distance Oberman and i talked about
having sort of a blue channel where you
were able to say what you really felt
during the highlights so if you didn't
like somebody language wasn't going to
be an issue you know maybe you just take
the baton and you know maybe late night
have some beverages Michael and just
just go blue and say whatever you want
about a player a team get a big sponsor
in there I like the idea of going blue
think about an after midnight show we're
literally you're on cable and you've got
a drink in each and you got a co-host
and you guys you just do random
commentaries and just go off as much as
you want the thing is is that there's
probably gonna be a group or some guy
that does that and makes a killing off
of it you could be that guy Michael Wow
you know do you want to work late at
night because you were in the morning
well I know you know that's funny is
that that was another thing is that
normally I have a show Monday through
Friday at 10:30 right so it's uh it's
very similar or to uh SVP except it's on
a regional level but so I'm I'm not
usually on 1:15 in the morning so that
was another factor you're to us like you
know what watching this right now it's
late raw tired let's just do this so we
always in fact normally if we have a
show that that plate will turn down a
little bit the studio and have some fun
with it it's actually not the first time
I've pretended to put on a drink on set
since it's so late I think you do a nude
sports cast we're like what but because
people thought we didn't wear pants when
we did SportsCenter so what if you just
had shirt tie sport coat and no pants on
and the thing is that I have a really
weird like misshapen body I feel like
people like the common man could relate
to that so you know that's that's my guy
right there you know he's showing off
but he has nothing to show off so you
know there may be a little niche there
for me to fill well you're now the the
sports casting Ron Burgundy scotch
scotch scotch scotch light
congratulations good to talk to you and
good luck
that's Michael Jenkins Comcast SportsNet
mid-atlantic Oh
still as a job the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience